[Musique]
nous sommes le 7 mars 2017 bonsoir et
bienvenue pour cette édition du 7 8
les invités émission consacrée à celles
et ceux qui font l'actualité du
département c'est sous l'étiquette 577
pour la france que jean christophe
fromantin maire de neuilly sur seine
entend présenter des candidats de la
société civile aux législatives et
nicolas jacquot 46 cents commerçants
entrepreneurs depuis 20 ans sur montigny
le bretonneux et l'un d'entre eux et
nous expliquera à ses motivations
lui qui s'engagent sur la première
circonscription à demain 8 mars journée
internationale des droits des femmes la
fédération française de cyclisme
s'engage à travers à l'opération elle à
vélo à vincent jacquet directeur
technique national va nous présenter la
soirée événement prévu au vélodrome à
montigny le bretonneux
bonsoir à tous les deux et bienvenue sur
ce plateau on va commencer par parler
politique vous êtes donc le candidat
nicolas jacquot dans la première
circonscription qui couvre je le
rappelle pour les téléspectateurs vers
ça et montigny ou encore guyancourt
représentait actuellement à l'assemblée
nationale par françois de mazières le
maire de versailles
vous êtes issu de la société civile vous
vous présenter sous l'étiquette 577 pour
la france votre volonté la volonté du
mouvement c'est de sortir du système
politique classique c'est assurer le
renouvellement de la classe politique
mais je crois que c'est quoi aujourd'hui
à sa classe politique de vivre entre
elles de vivre hors sol et d'être des
comptes déconnecté des réalités de la
vie quotidienne
et puis j'ai envie de dire quel que soit
le bord gauche ou droite
ce sont les mêmes systèmes ce sont les
mêmes renvoi d'ascenseur ce sont la même
organisation
on souffre je crois d'une déconnexion
grave du monde politique les dernières
affaires en sont l'illustration
jean christophe fromantin qui est à
l'origine du mouvement je leur précise
et maire de neuilly député de la 6e
circonscription des hauts-de-seine c'est
un ancien de l'udf gallois déçus du
système politique et des partis lui il
va renouveler cette classe politique par
la société civile vous le disiez qu'est
ce qui vous a séduit un petit peu dans
cette démarche pourquoi adhérer à ses
idées alors l'adhésion à ses idées c'est
autre chose mais la démarche c'est le
167 pour la france l'initiative 500
tonnes pour la france a comme
particularité qu'elle parle de la base
c'est à dire que dans le processus jean
christophe fromantin a été comme vous
l'avez dit élu député en 2012
il s'est rendu compte à l'assemblée
nationale de ce que je viens de vous
dire à savoir la déconnexion profonde
entre les élites qui nous dirigent et
qui font la vie quotidienne car un
député votre des lois qui s'appliquent
directement et qui joue sur les français
il s'est rendu compte de la 2 là je
dirais delà du fonctionnement
intrinsèquement endogène de ces hommes
politiques et du coup j'ai entendu
parler de son expérience je suis un
garçon qui habite montini depuis 25 ans
qui a un commerce de reprographie sur la
ville nouvelle
j'entends tous les jours des français de
toutes sortes de vraiment que j'ai une
vision de la société française très
régulière et je constate ce désarroi je
constate la puissance des gens à faire
avancer leur vie à ne pas comprendre les
lois qui sont prises et le mouvement
soit 177 pour la france d'abord le
parcours de jean christophe fromantin
qui a été élu en 2008 à neuilly contre
je dirais le système sarkozyste et le
système de l'ump de l'époque cheval de
le oui de l'époque
et son parcours est un est une réalité
cet effet c'est à dire c'est pas du
discours que c'est pas on va faire des
trucs super bien vous inquiétez pas
suivez moi c'est de dire un jour je me
présente contre le tir est le
le futur va le maire qui avait choisi
mais c'est sarkozy lorsqu'il est parti
elle présente de la république et puis
j'y vais comme ça avec avec sa volonté
et son envie sans investiture sans parti
sans soutien il a été élu si sept ans
plus tard il propose à travers les
médias moi j'ai appris ça par les médias
de réaliser la même opération à savoir
de partir de la base donc des candidats
de l'aps que j'appelle de la vraie vie
d'apporter leurs compétences leur
énergie et puis pour cela il
l'initiative 67 secret elle dit quoi
elle dit il faut signer une charte
on se reconnaît dans certaines valeurs
la principale à meyzieu et la tolérance
elle dit que ce n'est pas un parti pas
un mouvement c'est-à-dire que chaque
chaque candidat est libre on a des
sensibilités au sein de 67 différentes
et puis elle laisse la place j'ai envie
de dire à une logique d'individus
car je crois que la base de notre
système politique et sur une logique de
parti et c'est le problème c'est à dire
que on va pas faire le point de tout le
programme mais j'aimerais qu'on me
regarde un petit peu de temps tous même
pour en parler je n'ai juste un dernier
mot parce que vous parliez des affaires
françois fillon néanmoins a reçu le
soutien de jean christophe fromantin pas
de 177 pour la france je dirais et moi
j'apprécie la liberté et les convictions
de jean christophe fromantin je dirais
que d'autres autres cabero d'ailleurs ce
week-end voilà mais qui à mes yeux il
était à trith personnel et je comprends
d'ailleurs je comprends ses convictions
au sens où françois fillon il souffre de
quoi indépendamment des affaires qui à
mes yeux ne ne sont pas excusables je
dirais le français ne peut pas
comprendre ce genre de pratiques
françois fillon il souffre de la
préparation de la primaire qui souffrent
que dans la primaire personne n'est
prévu malgré que ce soit des gens
brillants qui ont été au gouvernement
qui ont été députés
personne n'a une sortie le courant le
fameux plan b dont on parle depuis le
plan b en tout cas les conditions qui
ferait que si le candidat gagnant la
primaire un accident si le candidat est
mise en examen si le candidat est
empêchée quelle est la solution
personne n'a prévu du coup moi je
considère que françois fillon bas il
trace son chemin dans l'ignorance des
statuts qui l'ont propulsé comme quand
on examine séparément christophe
fromantin le soutiennent malgré
l'initiative 577 moi je le jeune je suis
pour la liberté de chacun et en premier
lieu celle de jean-christophe fromantin
je dirais seulement qu'il faut faire une
déconnexion entre les candidats 177 pour
la france et le soutien apporté par jean
christophe fromantin qui à mes yeux
c'est sa liberté je trouve ça plutôt
sain parce qu'il a des convictions il
les affiches quel que soit ce que peut
bien penser les français en ce qui me
concerne je sais des pratiques que je ne
voudrais même pas qualifiés en plateau
quels sont vos mesures proposition vous
allez mettre en avant parce que se
revendiquer de la société civile c'est
très bien mais il faut aussi avancer des
propositions pour les premières
propositions j'ai envie de vous dire
c'est de rétablir la confiance c'est à
dire c'est du pragmatisme
je vais je crois que nous souffrons tous
de la confiance de la confiance entre la
population et la justice et la police
pardon de la confiance entre un
locataire et son propriétaire de la
confiance entre un employé et son
employeur et pour établir la confiance
il faut que les mesures que nous
prenions les lois que nous votions elle
soit dans le sens des citoyens
beaucoup beaucoup de boissons inutile la
dernière enfin la petite blague c'était
le voter le les alarmes anti-incendie
qu'est ce que vient faire l'assemblée
nationale là dedans sachant qu'on ne
peut pas contrôler l'application de ces
lois et que ça ne sert à rien ça relève
plus du domaine du lobbying qu'autre
chose la première mesure que je
prendrais en ce qui me concerne que je
m'appliquerai c'est la confiance
et elle passe parfois par la
transparence elle passe par une
permanence parlementaire ouverte et
accessible
elle passe par une perte une
transparence sur mes actes sur mes
rémunération sur l'organisation entre
guillemets d'une équipe de 2 qui serait
la mienne
elle passe par la capacité du député
assurer un lien un lien entre la
population et les différents services de
l'état parce que je crois que le député
ne se résume pas seulement à être de
temps en temps l'assemblée notamment le
mardi concert transmis et puis pour le
reste du temps à voter des lois sans
avoir forcément les avoir travaillé où
sont les proposer dans un premier temps
je dirais que la première chose pour
laquelle je milite c'est cette fameuse
confiance et ça passera obligatoirement
par la transparence quitte à bouleverser
quelques chapelles bien établis ou
effectivement on l'est sous la table et
c'est ce que les français ont découvert
avec la sphère filles ont des pratiques
parlementaires de gauche comme de droite
parce que fillon est le bouc émissaire
mais je crois par tout le monde l'a vu
il ya quand même un paquet de deux
parlementaires qui utilisent enfin
qu'ils ont c'est pratique c'est le sens
de mon engagement c'est vraiment ça y
est les propositions aussi un on
pourrait évoquer cette volonté de
transformer le sénat on assemblait des
territoires aussi alors fait un emprunt
national de 70 milliards de
euros pour financer un programme de
relance des investissements publics bien
évidemment nous aurons l'occasion
pendant la campagne des législatives
d'évoquer les propositions des
différentes formations différents
mouvements justin un dernier mot votre
regard sur le bilan du député sortant
qui ne se représente pas en raison du
non cumul des mandats également maire de
versailles je voudrais pas être trop cru
mais je crois qu'il n'y en a pas je
crois que si je regarde mon au niveau de
la circonscription il ya eu un certain
nombre de de communication
principalement axé sur la culture
jesson son grand dada pour le reste je
crois que les phares et les lésigny mon
teint ou légumes courtois nous ont
jamais entendu parler de leurs députés
je crois que il est inaccessible c'est à
dire que quelqu'un pour avoir pris un
rendez vous avec messieurs desmazières
dans sa mairie pour parler d'un problème
concret qui serait un problème de
transport un problème de justice sans
problème de logement ou un problème que
sais-je
j'aime regarder la seule chose qui est
visible le son classement dans le
dernier une agence privée qui a fait un
classement sur l' influence de députée
au niveau de l'assemblée nationale je
crois qu'ils se classer 350e un bilan
sévère très sévère et je crois que
monsieur de mazières qui ne se retirera
pas tout à fait est un peu l'image du
député tir qui est un haut fonctionnaire
qui a dirigé des choses publiques et qui
je suis pas certain qu'il ait un jour
chercher un logement qu'ils aient un
jour chercher une place en crèche ou un
jour régler un problème je vous arrête
là on aura l'occasion d'en parler lors
des prochains débats avec l'ensemble des
candidats qui seront organisés vous
restait néanmoins sur le plaisir allez
je vous remercie
cette suite les invités à présent c'est
avec cette opération organisée au
vélodrome vincent jacquet donc bonjour à
nouveau à bienvenue au delà taux
directeur technique national de la
fédération française de cyclisme
mercredi soir demain soir soirée
évènement 100% féminine autour du vélo
mais mais pas uniquement vous avez
décidé de d'ouvrir nos portes plusieurs
activités si on va pas dresser tout le
programme et quels sont les moments
forts de cette soirée du main or les
moments four sont
déjà la pratique la pratique cycliste un
faire de ceux de ce vélodrome super
vélodrome un lieu de pratique populaire
accessible à tous et est de montrer que
le cyclisme sur piste la pratique de
tous les cyclisme
il est évidemment au niveau féminin ça
c'est le premier point ensuite se
positionner aussi sur des ateliers qui
permettent à un moment donné de
travailler sur l'estimé de soi sur tout
ce qu'ils aient accès aux pratiques
ludiques tout ce qui est aussi lorsqu
une maman vient dans un club de sport la
possibilité de pour proposer des
activités aussi à ses enfants
donc cette multiplicité des activités au
féminin font qu'aujourd'hui on profite
de la journée du 8 pour pour montrer que
la pratique cycliste les toucher au
féminin l'événement mais l'année
dernière parce que ce n'est pas la
première fois que c est organisée au
vélodrome y est tout un projet de
démocratisation et d'ouverture du
cyclisme aux femmes aussi parce qu'on
peut donner un chiffre 1 10 % des
licenciés de la fédération seulement oui
ce sont des fans allemands seulement
vous vous posez un constat qui est pour
nous très très insuffisant effectivement
120 mille licenciés 10 % ça fait douze
mille on a 14 millions de pratiquants en
france des activités du cyclisme
l'objectif est d'attirer public féminin
dans nos clubs
le jeune public féminin c'est tout
autant pour les garçons que pour les
filles
donc on a toute une démarche pédagogique
qui était en voie est engagée
2 parce ce coût de lancement l'année
dernière à la même date
c'est la deuxième édition de pouvoir
doter les clubs doter les acteurs du
cyclisme en france d'un kit pédagogique
qui permet de monter des programmes au
féminin d'accueillir les féminines dans
les clubs de développer la prise de
responsabilité de nos féminines dans les
actions dirigeante donc réellement tout
une démarche qui nous permet qui va nous
permettre d'une part de montrer que le
cyclisme c'est au féminin mais aussi de
fidéliser et de développer toutes ses
actions ce qui explique que ce soit 6
difficile de séduire ce public féminin
autour de parties cyclisme parce qu'on a
on a souvent eu tendance à travailler
sur l'image de la sportive de haut
niveau qui ne parlent pas tout le monde
le parler vrai on le disait tout à
l'heure aujourd'hui tous ces aspects
sport en famille tous ses aspects ce
pourrait bien être sport santé spots hic
s'adresse tout autant à une une franche
delà de la population qui qui aiment
pratiquer la frange féminine et qui
aiment pratiquer aussi avec des copines
avec ses enfants avec son mari est
effectivement pouvoir développer ce type
d'activités loisirs pour bien évidemment
démocratiser vous avez aussi un certain
soutien des médias malgré tout puisque
france télévisions sera présent
dominique oui c'est l'un de nos
partenaires là aussi dans le cadre
d'engagements des médias sur sur
l'action promotion des activités
sportives au féminin on a la chance
d'avoir un tout le sport en direct est
derrière tout une démarche
d'accompagnement qui va nous permettre
je l'espère de pouvoir bien communiquer
mais pas obligé de rester chez vous pour
suivre cette retransmission sur france
télévisions bien évidemment vous avez
rendez vous au vélodrome en alors
dupliquer à grenoble à bordeaux à
roubaix où il ya des vélodromes en
france qui qui ont pris le virus donc
non non c'est très sympa et ça
commencera à partir de 18 heures
et oui aux installations 17 oui 18h10 -
les larmes de piste et beaucoup
d'ateliers très ludiques qui permettent
de fidéliser ce public féminin et vous
parlais juste un dernier mot de ce kit
de féminisation ça veut dire que
concrètement comment vous allez aider
les dirigeants qu'est ce qu'on trouve
sur ce qu'ils plat comment on sait de
l'interactif cd contenu c'est des
tutoriels c'est des méthodes c'est dé
progression pédagogique pour les jeunes
féminines et s'est aussi positionné dans
le cadre des projets de territoire et
les projets de club
7c'est ibles qui est ô combien
importante dans la vie publique
merci d'être venu nous présenter cette
soirée elle à vélo ce sera demain au
vélodrome à saint quentin en yvelines et
pas seulement il ya plusieurs vélodrome
vous l'avez rappelé qu'ils sont
mobilisés on en parlera bien évidemment
dans les prochaines éditions du journal
et des invités sur cette antenne
merci également d'être venu nous parler
d'eux et fiat yves 577 le moment là
elle vous êtes en victime encore payne
rencontre rencontres échanges
merci à tous les deux en tous cas un
petit tour au vélodrome auparavant et
puis ensuite pour la politique merci à
tous les deux et à bientôt
[Musique]